on my orders Coalition forces have begun
striking selected targets of military
importance to undermine Saddam Hussein's
ability to wage war
these are opening stages of what will be
a broad and concerted campaign
Monday marks 20 years since the
beginning of the U.S led invasion of
Iraq the war which lasted until 2011 was
launched to depose Iraqi dictator Saddam
Hussein and to confiscate weapons of
mass destruction weapons that were never
found more than eight thousand Americans
lost their lives during the conflict
along with hundreds of thousands of
Iraqis CBS News Chief foreign
correspondent Charlie dagada covered The
Invasion and the war back in 2003 two
decades later he is back in Baghdad
it began with the campaign of shock and
awe
a display of overwhelming force and
Firepower
within weeks U.S ground forces were
closing in on the capitol
when U.S Marines pulled Saddam Hussein
off his plinth in Baghdad Iraqi crowds
pounced around six weeks after it
started President George W bush
announced the end of major combat
operations
major combat operations in Iraq have
ended
in the Battle of Iraq
the United States and our allies have
prevailed
under the banner mission accomplished
the mission was far from accomplished
a deadly Insurgency was growing in
strength and number there were hopes to
capture Saddam Hussein in December that
year might quell the violence but the
ferocity of the resistance only
intensified and toppling Saddam gave way
to a brutal and bloody sectarian Civil
War we covered the first Democratic
elections were you afraid to come out
where Iraqis defied death threats to
take part in the vote Susan there are
explosions to report we've heard them
all morning in Baghdad the war took a
heavy toll the death of hundreds of
thousands of Iraqis by some estimates
and nearly 4 500 American Service
members were killed before President
Barack Obama pulled the last troops out
of Iraq in 2011. they were soon back
when Isis rampaged across 40 percent of
this country just cleared this area a
few days ago they say tired of things
finally in Iraq in 2017.
a country exhausted by this sheer
Bloodshed sectarian violence began to
subside and security improved
20 years after the invasion in most of
Baghdad looks like this no longer a war
zone gone or the cement blast walls and
Barbed wires the shops and cafes and
Market places like this are open and
they're busy residents here are hopeful
if not necessarily optimistic for
peaceful future
like many young people twenty-year-old
nabal laith has High Hopes the life this
year is very good but while Iraq's
future may look bright it also remains
precarious
that is the first time we've been able
to walk freely around open markets for
years now there are still 2500 U.S
forces here commanders say that's in
order to keep Isis in check but many
Iraqis say the real reason is to serve
as a hedge against Iran and not everyone
here is happy about it for CBS Saturday
morning Charlie dagada Baghdad